if you're thinking of starting the
business and you're worried that you
don't have the resources connections and
the timing may not be perfect to start
your business I'm gonna give you advice
on how to start with what you have hi
I'm Evan Carmichael I believe in
entrepreneurs and I got a great question
for one of my YouTube viewers love you
guys Armando who wrote in the say I've
already learned with photographers I
just want to know if I can start with
some cheap equipment first and then work
my way up buying better cameras and
equipment should I take pictures mostly
outside to begin and then get a studio
or use my home to take pictures that I
just need to start a business ASAP so I
can pay my bills I'm real good and
taking pictures lighting making kids
smile and laugh I have people who would
be able to help me get customers so let
me know your opinion advice Thank You
Armando Armando this is a fantastic
question and so many entrepreneurs wait
for the perfect time to start their
business they wait to have the resources
they wait to have the money they wait to
have the connections they wait for that
client to fall in their lap the timing
is never perfect to start a business if
you love it you just have to start you
see so many entrepreneurs focus on what
you don't have you focus on the gear and
the equipment and the team that you
don't have you focus on the connections
that you don't have the investors that
you don't have the media and the press
that you don't have and if that's all
you focus on then you will never start
your business because the lines will
never be fully connected the key is a
start with what you have and start today
when I started my youtube business as an
example I didn't have any expensive
camera or gear I started doing myself on
my crappy little flip cam and as I got
better I started to build an audience
and started to make some money off of
the videos then I could invest it back
into better gear I'm now working on a
camera that's worth over two thousand
dollars but that wasn't my first camera
even after I started making some money I
went to Costco and started buying a
camera better and the camera better and
a camera better and slowly started
spending more and more money again as I
saw results in my business if I waited
for the perfect timing and for the
perfect camera to fall in my lap I would
have never started this channel and you
guys the YouTube community believe
nation have become such a powerful force
for me it's one of my favorite parts of
the day
is waking up everyday and seeing your
comment I can't imagine my life now
without that and it it wouldn't have
been possible if I didn't just start
with what I had so don't be afraid just
start even if all you have is an iPhone
start with that start a bonus tip that I
want to add in here is to be resourceful
as entrepreneurs you're always going to
be limited in the early days of how many
resources you have but you should be
unlimited in your resource fulness find
a way to get the stuff that you need and
some of my first videos I had a friend
who was in video production and he came
and filmed my very first video with Walt
Disney's story as I wanted to grow and
expand and get my own gear I borrowed a
friend's more professional ish camera
over what I had to try and test it out
in some of the videos you have friends
use them ask them for help be
resourceful
you're gonna need their support as you
go because you can't do this alone
and of course belief thank you guys so
much for watching I love to hear how you
started and what limited resources you
had and how you broke through or how
you're still trying to break through if
you want to leave a comment below and of
course if you liked this video and you
want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon